welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the next chapter for black
panther in the marvel cinematic universe
is a huge
unknown between the tragic loss of
chadwick boseman and the studio's
repeated schedule shakeups
it's hard to know or to even talk about
how the mcu could move on but whatever
marvel is planning for wakanda's future
just got a potentially huge clue from
the recently released in-universe book
the wakanda files
a trove of canonical details about the
weapons and tech of the mcu
revealed by shuri's journal entries are
you there bost it's me shuri and a
camoyabead uv light that you probably
won't want to point anywhere else
now i explored how this book revealed
tony stark's secret insights and
experiences with time travel but really
the major bombshell is shuri's
experiments to
re-grow the mystical heart-shaped herb
of wakanda that superpowers the black
panther
and was supposedly eradicated by fire by
killmonger in the first film nokia
managed to salvage
one of the plants to resuscitate
t'challa but it appeared as though all
the others had burned
leaving the question of who could take
over after t'challa a mystery
even before bozeman's passing but are
all the heart-shaped herbs truly gone
from wakanda
are they well according to this marvel
book reviewed by sci-fi wire after
killmonger burned all the heart-shaped
herbs
shuri began looking into a way to
synthesize the plant
via botanical research she noted that
she
considered stabilizing the effects of
the synthetic herb by mixing in
vibranium but
that she couldn't really move forward
until she studied
a sample of the original plant shuri
also noted an interest in the extremist
research by maya hansen that's the aim
botanist from iron man 3 who worked
under aldrich killian
shuri wrote that if you treat the human
brain like a supercomputer you can make
it think that it has the abilities
of cytosine and oxin like in plants
which could let the body regrow lost
appendages
an idea that she described as having
potential
now the go-to implication that you might
be thinking about is a possible
intention by shuri to regrow the
heart-shaped derb for her
own personal use after black panther
came out a couple years back many of us
speculated that shuri would one day take
on the black panther mantle herself with
her own vibranium suit following her arc
in the comics
and while i do think that is definitely
in the works for shuri's future we
should i think
pump the brakes and remember that there
are many ways ryan coogler and the
filmmaking team could go
latisha wright for her part said that
when it comes to black panther 2 quote
we're just still mourning chad so it's
not something i even want to think about
the thought of doing it without him is
kind of strange we're just grieving at
the moment so it's trying to find the
light in the midst of it
perfectly stated i should also point out
that the passage from this wakandaphiles
book explicitly leaves the door open to
a natural solution
with shuri still needing a sample from
an original plant to move forward
and re-watching black panther there is
an interesting moment in the minutes
after killmonger torches a garden when
nakia brings the plant to
umbaku in the mountain tribe her
original plan was to let mbaku consume
the plant so that he could challenge
killmonger for the throne now of course
umbaku shortly after revealed that
t'challa was still alive but we were
always left with that interesting
hypothetical contingency of
baku stepping up his black panther why
did he refuse this option like he didn't
have to tell them that t'challa was
still alive
sure killmonger did defeat t'challa and
t'challa had defeated mbaku but i don't
think maku was driven by fear in this
moment
loyalty to t'challa after t'challa
spared him at warrior falls
maybe or perhaps another reason because
watch m'baku closely in this scene
this is why we are here to offer this to
you
[Music]
come with me yeah i think we missed
something there
but while we're talking about super
powered things we can consume and juice
up and power on
thanks to a real-life version of that
bang energy for sponsoring this video
yum every can of bang is 16 ounces
it contains 300 milligrams of caffeine
whoa it's sugar-free and it has
zero calories yet it tastes really good
bang there are over 20 different flavors
to choose from one of those great
flavors is
cotton candy do you know what cotton
candy is it's just a cloud of sweet
this is what it tastes like if that
cloud were to just rain a sip in your
mouth
that sip turns into a carnival that
keeps you moving on all day long
check out bang on instagram you can get
25
off your order at bang energy.com when
you use the code newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea ketu coffee
flavors
bankster berry purple guava pear star
blast
pina colada there's all kinds of great
flavors you can also get clothing
fitness supplements all kinds of stuff
to be your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video get 25
off at bang energy.com using the code
new rockstars25 okay so what original
plant sample could shuri have been
referring to in these wakanda files
from what we know of the heart-shaped
herb it was grown exclusively in the
royal gardens of the wakandan palace
catacombs originally it sprung up wildly
in the wakandan soil enriched by the
vibranium meteorite with the original
black panther led to it by
bost then over the years the ruling
tribe must have cultivated this strain
so that it grew only in their private
garden since
it was the source of their power but we
do know there are far
reaches of this kingdom that are pretty
closed off from the main tribes four
tribes agreed to live under the king's
rule
but the jabari tribe isolated themselves
in the mountains
which brings us back to maku in this
moment
could the true reason he refused nakia's
heart-shaped herb
be that the jabari already have their
own secret strain of this plant
growing in their mountain caves a plant
maku has
already consumed yet still
embarrassingly
failed to overcome a de-powered t'challa
at warrior falls
that humbling defeat could be what keeps
umbaku quiet here to take a purely grown
original strain of the plant after he's
already taken his version
could have unknown effects and likely
force him to admit he tried to give
himself an unfair advantage before
really i think some possible smoking gun
evidence of imbaku's secret plant
consumption
could have just revealed itself seconds
earlier when he jokingly threatened ross
you cannot talk one more word
and i will feed you to my children
i'm kidding we are vegetarians now yes
this could just be interpreted as a joke
referencing
baku's problematic cannibalistic origins
in the comics but what if there's more
to it
that the reason for the jabari's insane
strength not just at warrior falls but
in the final battle
is the fact that they have been
consuming as part of a regular
vegetarian diet
a sister strain of the heart-shaped herb
not only would that strain's existence
give wakanda and shuri a way forward to
regrow the heart-shaped herb
it would give mbaku a critical role in
that narrative
something he absolutely deserves
considering he was at t'challa and
akoya's side
not just in the battle against
killmonger but against thanos forces in
infinity war and in the battle of earth
and in game but it would do so in a way
that still honors the incarnation of
black panther t'challa played by
chadwick boseman a warrior so strong
that
even when stripped of his superpowers
facing others with
untold hidden strengths still he powered
through and exemplified a value for life
and for
friendship what better tribute than that
i certainly prefer black panther and
baku to
like sure using iron man 3 extremist
goosebumps don't go in the basement [ __ ]
to reanimate the flesh of killmonger's
corpse he was the guy who burned all
those plants to begin with i think he
made his statement and is stronger when
he is still dead but again however the
black panther creative team decides to
move on here
we are in no rush and it is totally
understandable to still hold chadwick's
memory in our hearts and for that to be
the priority for now
look it's fun to discuss the
implications of new canonical details as
they come up but of course we do not
need firm answers about his replacement
just yet in the meantime discuss these
nerdy theories with me on new rockstar's
official discord server by becoming a
patron at patreon.comrockstars subscribe
to rockstars here on youtube hit that
notification bell follow me on instagram
ea boss follow new rockstars thank you
for watching and remember
vote
[Music]
you